so what's up jamie ted lasso
ah he's really cutting up your bum
hasn't he he's not even a real coach
so without further ado with the new
manager of afc richmond
ted lasso ted is a small time
american football coach gets hired to
coach a professional soccer team in the
uk
jesus he doesn't know the rules of
football when he comes here but
our favorite version of an american
character is ignorant with curiosity
why don't we just jump right in anybody
got any questions
oh yeah no i should have saw that coming
for a tv show about football which is
obviously
very male dominated we have two super
strong
female characters what does it do again
i'm sort of famous
for being almost famous maybe think of
it as a plant
rebecca and keeley i think when you
first meet them are
very different women who you might think
might not get along and
actually become extraordinarily
wonderful friends made me think of you
it's strong and a bit prickly it's
really funny
and it's sort of secretly a little bit
deep
but don't tell anything when i said that
i think people will fall in love with
ted and i think they'll like the message
that he's bringing
which is you don't necessarily have to
be
an expert in everything you don't have
to pretend you're something you're not
you can just be you
and you can be a success by being kind
and gracious and thoughtful how you feel
yeah just
to know there's so many new feelings
right yeah i like getting your first
pube right oh yeah here we go
even if it's written in a way where
there's just pure humor in it ted is
somebody that would expand your mind
when you don't realize it's
happening all the characters who come
across ted are changed by
in an amazing heartwarming way i have a
real tricky time hearing folks that
don't believe in themselves so i'm gonna
ask you real quick again do you think
this idea will work
yeah i do whoa why are you screaming at
us
nate we're right here it's a genuinely
funny show and if you've got 30 to 40
minutes you're not gonna regret watching
it
i don't think i can get over that
anymore sure you could passion's all
about confidence
you know if i didn't have any confidence
i never would have worn pajamas to my
prom and
ended up in jail the rest of that night
but you don't want to hear that story so
i go into it